This video is brought to you by verve.
Hey,
wise crack Helen here.
So jarrod's taking a breather this
month,
which means I have the honor of telling
you guys all about one of the most
beloved and Van Request An enemies in
wise crack history.
Cowboy Bebop,
yes,
we're finally doing it.
So what's taken us so long?
Well,
when we sat down to analyze what makes
cowboy bebop stow amazing from it's
super fluid fight scenes too,
it's insane.
Grab bag of a soundtrack.
We kept running into the same problem.
Every episode is a kaleidoscope of
references,
philosophies,
narratives and forms.
It seems downright impossible to pull on
just one thread.
Then around the beginning of season two
we noticed this interstitial,
yeah,
it might be hard to read,
but it says then in 2071 in the
universe,
the bounty hunters who are gathering in
spaceship Bebop,
we'll play freely without fear of risky
things.
They must create new dreams and films by
breaking traditional styles.
The work which becomes a new genre
itself will be called Cowboy bebop.
If those last two sentences about
breaking traditional styles and creating
a new genre that really gave us pause.
See,
cowboy bebop isn't just about great
characters and deep thoughts.
It's about blurring the line between
three distinct genres,
Saifai,
westerns and no arm.
So welcome to this wise crack addition
on cowboy bebop and you guessed it,
spoilers ahead.
And thanks again to our sponsor.
[inaudible] throw your one stop shop for
Anamae science fiction and so much more.
If you're a cowboy bebop fan,
be sure to check out their new show,
kill joys to get your bounty hunters in
space fix for a free 30 day trial,
go to [inaudible] dot com slash wise
crack.
Now back to the show.
First a quick refresher course set in
the year 2071 cowboy bebop follows a
group of starving bounty hunters who
wonder from planet to planet looking for
their next meal ticket.
There's jet,
a former detective who's rocking the
robocop look on his left arm spike,
a modern take on the Marlboro man mixed
with the tragic mob back story.
They authentic,
they tall dealing with gambling problems
and a serious case of Amnesia.
And,
um,
ed,
who's a brilliant hacker.
But really,
yeah,
she's just it together in more or less
episodic fashion.
The team hunts down fugitives while
shoveling down some pretty meager meals
aside from an ongoing fight with hunger.
The first thread you'll notice in cowboy
bebop is its unique take on the side by
genre.
The show challenges our idea of Scifi,
but presenting a future that doesn't
really have much to do with the future.
Sure.
There are all the familiar trappings
here after the destruction of a giant
space portal that lets you travel the
universe at and your lightspeed earth
has been left near uninhabitable and
mankind has spread throughout the
universe.
And for those of you who grew up on
things like star wars or Gundam Wing,
you'll notice a medley of conventions,
epic space battles check terrifying,
mysterious alien creatures.
Check space terrorist.
Sure why not.
But the longer you inhabit the world of
Cowboy Bebop,
the more you realize it's brand of Scifi
isn't about portraying the future.
In fact,
it feels more like the 90s and it does
2071 cities here aren't the shining
beacons on the hill.
That future is and promised us.
Instead they're dirty,
almost run down.
Hell.
There's a whole space colony full of
drifters and riff raff and technology
isn't exactly 70 years ahead of its time
either.
Take session seven for example,
heavy metal queen in it,
we see the ins and outs of space
transportation through the lens of the
best truck or there is the tea,
but it quickly becomes apparent that
much hasn't changed for future trucking.
Space trucks are still adorned with hood
ornaments.
Their cabins are still cramps to cedars
crammed with personal knickknacks.
They even communicate via radio add
though on La [inaudible] whole new
[inaudible] radio people and when it's
time to wind down there,
relax at crappy rest stops,
which look identical to the ones I've
seen in west Tennessee.
So what's going on here?
What are we to make of Psi Phi that
doesn't really make use of the science
part in a flashier way as wise crack
favorite ray Bradbury tells us,
science fiction is the fiction of
revolutions.
Revolutions in time,
space,
medicine,
travel and thought.
Above all,
science fiction is the fiction of warm
blooded human men and women sometimes
elevated and sometimes crushed by their
machines.
In other words,
at the heart of any good Saifai story
then are the people and their stories in
which machines are only apart
Bradbury's.
Words go a long way in explaining why we
continually see stories and cowboy bebop
that are surprisingly light on the
technology that surrounds them.
Perhaps there's no better example of
this then Fay Valentine.
In many ways,
Faye is a victim of sciences progress.
When she and her family traveled to
space aboard their private shuttle,
something goes horribly wrong.
Leaving Fay as the only survivor about
her injuries are so severe,
the doctors decide to cryogenically free
sir until she can be saved by later
medical advancements.
Over 50 years pass and Faye is awoken by
the questionably named physician doctor
Baucus except there's only one problem.
Dallas.
It they all had to go to dona.
Yup.
She lost her memory worse because the
gate exploded while she was frozen.
There's no surviving data on who fay
even was before.
Id this,
what are the juvenile machine
[inaudible]
and did we mention she's now drowning in
debt checky had I not done yet.
Despite science and technology nearly
screwing Fay at every turn,
they story is never folded into a
warning about the future or it's
technology instead.
Phase journey is all about finding a
place to belong,
a pretty common literary trope across
all genres at the sea.
[inaudible] yeah,
two button.
Sure.
Elements of science fiction setup,
phase narrative,
but at the end of the day they're just
silent cues that help move the conflict
along by letting science elements do
their work in the background.
Cowboy bebop really thrust its
characters into the spotlight,
which is maybe why with only 10 out of
26 episodes exploring our heroes,
personal stories,
we're still able to relate so much to
them.
Seriously.
Guys who did not feel like crying when
phages lies down in the wreckage of her
childhood home.
But saifai isn't the only genre cowboy
bebop works in.
Yeah,
if the title wasn't enough of a dead
giveaway.
Cowboy bebop also plays heavily with
western conventions more than anything.
The first session,
asteroid blues really sets the tone and
the episode Jen and Spike Hunt Down the
drug dealer asthma of Solon son and his
girlfriend catarina in Tiawana there
saloon fights and Stetson hats.
Indigenous wise men,
we even see spike wearing a Poncho and
Sombrero at one point and true to form
even the episodes ending itself is an
homage to classic western themes.
Catarina realizing the jet and the
authorities are closing in on them.
The sides to take drastic action.
Adios.
As literary critic Peter French notes.
While rare when suicide is depicted in
Westerns,
it has shown to be the escape of the
week or the defeated.
For French,
though nothing characterizes westerns
more than death and that's particularly
true in cowboy bebop,
French rights.
The Western is about a dead man's walk
or run or Gallup.
It is not accidental that so many of the
heroes and villains of Westerns are
portrayed as having a previous history
in the American civil war on the losing
confederate side.
They have been defeated and lift with
death and Gore in a cause.
They we are led to believe,
saw either as they're inescapable duty
or as romantic.
So you're a man's only good for one.
All did at time.
I took mine to the confederate states of
America today,
Joe Sam.
This concept of a dead man's walk
becomes particularly relevant with spike
just as Western heroes aimlessly wander
through life carrying the burden of the
romantic cause,
which has now been extinguished so to,
to spike meander through life,
carrying his tragic romance with him,
a romance that almost killed him.
The first detail we learn about spike is
that he's already died once before my
mouth.
Duh.
What did I [inaudible] [inaudible]
a former Hitman for the Red Dragon
Syndicate.
Spike wanted to escape with the love of
his life.
Julia after performing one last job
except Julianne never showed up and the
spikes partner,
well,
let's just say he's named vicious for a
reason.
In the end,
spike barely managed to escape with his
life,
with everyone in his old life believing
he died.
But instead of washing his hands of
everything spike holds on old in all
Nola just as French described with
Westerns,
spike can never fully tear himself away
from his bloody past.
Whether it's to bring a bounty on his
former boss,
wall socket,
Walmart,
mono cause she said when you got or to
chase after the woman he loves or to
settle the score with vicious spike
returns time and time again to his past.
Considering Spike nearly dies every time
he runs after his past.
We've got to wonder what duty could be
so important,
especially since he once told Faye that
the past doesn't matter anymore.
Dakota,
golden winkeljohn and Blah,
doug about
cargo,
all the water meter you out with that
all well,
digging deeper into the genre,
the answer isn't too much of a stretch.
As literary critic Jane Tompkins notes
in her book west of everything.
The heroes and villains of Westerns
aren't concerned with traditional Judeo
Christian ethics.
The harsh reality of the desert and
they're outlawed in lifestyles won't
allow it.
Instead,
their moral code revolves around honor
as French elaborates.
What after all is the value of residents
in the Kingdom of Heaven?
If the cost is one self respect,
we see this in almost every character
from spikes past but most vividly in a
vicious,
vicious ever.
The sociopath holds a mite is right
attitude.
Those who can't or won't fight according
to vicious shouldn't be allowed to live.
It's the reason why he killed his boss
and later stage to coop.
It's also the reason why he seeks to
kill spike,
the man who has renounced his violent
past.
We'll wait.
[inaudible] this new shoe modeling.
Some of you came on though so much
trouble.
Son Christopher Nolan,
but even vicious,
seemingly wants a fair fight with spike.
He passed up easy opportunities to kill
his mortal foe when spike was passed out
on one of Jupiter's moons.
This just leaves him unharmed,
mostly tall.
No,
I'm not at the home and when spike and
vicious or in their final duel,
they both passed their own preferred
weapons to each other instead of either
taking the advantage.
As for spike,
his decision to kill vicious isn't about
him being a serious piece of shit.
In part,
it's about writing a personal wrong
Julia's death as French reminds us,
the hero of a western is not the cowboy
equivalent of the caped crusader.
The wrongs must always relate to some
harm suffered either by him directly or
by someone with whom he has established
a relationship,
but there's also a more philosophical
reason behind spikes decision and it has
to do with skepticism.
Since leaving the syndicate,
Spike has wondered if he ever really
survived at all wondering if what he saw
was real cuddle.
No real
did you call,
didn't have Christmas Day cutoff.
[inaudible] called the hold on medical
call me day.
Many me fucking I came to Janae
specifically.
Spike continually floats the idea that
everything he sees could just be a
dream.
[inaudible] emailed me.
In this sense,
spike echoes the skepticism of ancient
Chinese philosopher lungs up who roped.
Once upon a time I [inaudible] was a
butterfly fluttering hither and thither.
To all intents and purposes,
a butterfly.
I was conscious only of my happiness as
a butterfly on aware that I was one
zone.
Soon I awake and there I was there to
bleed myself again.
Now I do not know whether I was then a
man dreaming I was a butterfly or
whether I am now a butterfly dreaming I
am a man spike struggling to make sense
of life before and after the syndicate
wonders if maybe he never really left
the syndicate at all.
He wonders if he really died that night.
It's only after losing the love of his
life that he accepts the cruel reality
of the situation.
He's been awake the whole time.
[inaudible] it's anybody can submit you
for spike.
His dead man's walk isn't just to take
revenge on vicious.
It's paradoxically to show himself that
he's awake or as he tells Fay shitty new
coworkers.
Nay.
Yeah.
Putting a halt on each to Ricardo car.
And while it's up for debate,
whether spike dies after his final fight
with vicious,
I've got to say,
spike would make clint eastwood proud by
storming vicious his hideout.
Oh.
And wondering why vicious and spike and
go at it with the Katana and a pistol
and the whole fight still feels
believable.
Yeah.
It's because Ronin films,
you know,
Japanese period pieces that followed the
loan.
Samurai dispensing personal justice are
pretty much the cultural equivalent of
Westerns.
In fact,
from the epic one,
men armies to the tent silence before
the dual westerns in Ronan's have
created a fairly shared visual and
thematic identity.
But that's another video.
Finally,
the third and perhaps most notable genre
cowboy bebop works in is no are
strangely no.
Our is notoriously hard for film critics
to define.
For example,
Raymond Board and Etienne show Matam
defined it in their seminal text,
a panorama of American film,
the war as having five feet
characteristics,
dreamlike,
strange,
erotic,
ambivalent,
and cruel,
but many popular noir.
Our films don't hit all the marks while
every character is influenced by film
noir.
Jimmy.
No,
he's telling me it's the book.
Can you come by?
I think the genre has the greatest pool
on Faye and jet.
Sorry.
Spike thing is clearly a femme fatale
one,
a film noirs favorite conventions.
See one film,
no,
our first captured the popular
imagination following World War II.
There were few representations of women
that depicted them as anything other
than swooning,
fainting,
walking pairs of ovaries.
But as literary scholar,
Jamie place notes,
no war changed that and became one of
the few periods of film in which women
are active,
not static.
Symbols are intelligent and powerful if
destructively so and derive power,
not weakness from their sexuality.
They is definitely intelligent,
powerful in sexual.
She's constantly one step ahead of her
male peers.
Gee,
you took on a [inaudible] [inaudible] na
gene Kolkata dinner
and she isn't above using her sexuality
to get what she wants.
That's good.
And whilst some like critic Julie
Grossman have criticized the trope for
being an overly simplistic reduction of
lady agency in the world,
Faye is a little more dynamic.
In fact,
she's the only character who really
makes us substantive and channel change
by the series end,
but her narrative arc also taps into the
very philosophical spine of know are
nihilism.
Yes,
I know nihilism has become wise cracks.
Favorite dead horse,
but hey,
I didn't put it in the Zeitgeists.
According to literary critic Mark Conrad
Nawar Develop as a consequence of the
20th century ushering out old belief
systems,
when Nisha famously proclaimed God is
dead,
he was making a statement that these
seeming like a turtle systems like God,
morality or even truth,
we're illusions.
Reality to Nisha is in constant flux,
which means things like definitions,
constants,
and even being don't exist over time,
whether he was right or wrong,
Nisha was correct in predicting the
mass,
alienation and loneliness brought on by
the disillusionment of these systems.
As science chipped away at our happy
belief systems in the 20th century,
people became lost.
An anxious and wise crack was born.
Conrad Rights.
Seeing the war as a response or reaction
to the death of God helps explain the
commonality of the elements that critics
have noted in new our films.
The inherent pessimism,
alienation and disorientation.
And if there's one character who's
continually had belief system after
belief system ripped away from her,
it's Fay.
When fay first awakes,
she doesn't actually believe that she's
in the future.
That is until your lawyer's teller that
she's got it all wrong.
And you sent him book cause you were
hunting
in this sort of [inaudible] Cintiq yes.
And if waking up in an unrecognizable
future sounds bad,
try adding trust issues.
When Faye finds out that her old lawyer,
you know the one she fell in love with
had faked his death,
you can bet your bottom dollar that she
felt the same lonely anxiety that Nisha
had described.
Many of whom today [inaudible] and Faye
experiences the ultimate disillusionment
when she finds out that the goal she's
been searching for her past is gone
after Ed takes page of the place where
she grew up.
The two are greeted by an old classmate
emphasis on old,
oh not though this you Saudi,
you.
Hi Scooter.
No Tokina dual cuna time like niches,
idea of reality is in constant motion
and it's left fay behind realizing that
she can never get her old life back.
They calls herself a ghost,
but got an eye this year.
[inaudible] as she later tells spike the
life that she thought she wanted,
the home that she wanted to return to
his no more fake is not the only know
our s character who's a trench coat
wearing cop for a number says
sweetheart.
Like this.
Yeah,
it's everyone's favorite chef jess like
faith.
Just the backdrop borrows heavily from
no our conventions.
A former cop jet suffered two massive
blows in his past.
First,
his lover walked out on him without
warning
what you know,
cleared dixter dog Solo Tokyo dogging on
mogul Tita [inaudible] sooner
and second,
he was nearly killed when he cornered a
syndicate assassin.
Oh,
and did I mention jets nickname?
[inaudible] on.
Oh,
could I cheat.
Dot.
[inaudible]
so we've got a former cop turned pie.
I mean bounty hunter who's pining over a
loss love.
Yeah,
it's no arm like Fay jet has to learn.
The time moves forward and with it
everyone else consider the pocket.
Watch the jets lover.
Alyssa left him.
I [inaudible] I said it though.
Well,
the symbolism might be a bit heavy
handed here.
Jet Holding onto the broken watch
represents his desire to return to the
past to a time when his watch still tit
and Elisa waited for him to come home
from work.
But when jet seeks answers about the
past,
he's reminded that it's long gone.
Elisa has a new life and a new boyfriend
and only jet is wondering why.
Worse when a lease a finally gives jet
the answers he's looking for,
they shatter his ideas of the past.
As it turns out,
jets relationship wasn't so perfect and
Elisa felt trapped.
That's what he eats.
And what that does,
the three to tookie he's jacking.
Yeah.
In the end,
jet can't return to his past because
this idealized past never existed at
all.
Looking back at that interstitial about
playing without fear of risky things,
breaking traditional styles and creating
new genres,
it's hard to argue that series director,
she needs zero Watanabe didn't do just
that in cowboy bebop.
Saifai westerns.
No,
are even a little Ronan action.
It's all here and it's all excellent.
It's this very genre bending that's made
the series so popular and it's the
reason why cowboy bebop seems so fresh
two decades later and there's nothing
like the story that can withstand the
test of time.
If Cowboy Bebop,
Scott,
you feeling nostalgic,
get excited,
you can find all your old favorites plus
tons of great new series on verb
dragonball,
super mega low box cowboy,
bebop,
onepiece and tons more.
Personally,
I'm a subs overdubs kind of Gal,
but one of the best things about verb is
that it gives you both and when you've
had your fix of anime,
there's so much more to see,
like all 354 episodes of star gate or
the story of another space bounty hunter
crew in the new show,
kill joys from [inaudible] with birth
premium.
You'll even be able to watch all your
shows on the go without Internet for a
limited time,
get a 30 day free trial of birth premium
at [inaudible] dot com slash wise crack.
This is,
we'll give you ad free access to 13
channels such as crunchy roll,
Rooster Teeth,
animation,
cartoon hangover,
drama,
fever,
curiosity stream,
and more.
Their latest channel,
nick splat even features bro back
episodes from nineties nick interested
yet,
check it out by heading to [inaudible]
dot com slash wise crack or equivalent,
a link in the description.
That's all for now.
See a space cowboy.
Okay.